>> From the Library of Congress
in Washington D.C.
>> I'd like to introduce our
presenters for this afternoon.
Carissa Pastuch is a Description Coordinator for
the World Digital Library, also known as WDL,
and is involved at all stages
of the production process.
She collaborates with WDL
partners around the world
with in-house [inaudible] and with contractors.
She works with scholars and language
experts in the editorial process
to create the most accurate
descriptions with authoritative metadata.
In 2014 she received dual masters
degrees from the University of Arizona
in Middle East Studies and Library Science.
Cecilia Penaloza is the Program
Specialist of WDL.
And as a main liaison between WDL and
its partners, she steers communications
for efficient content ingestion,
monitors compliance with legal aspects
of WDL's international partnerships
and reports on website user statistics.
She designs WDL's promotional materials
and pursues new outreach opportunities.
Cecilia has a BFA in design,
Aesthetic Philosophy degree and an MA
in Museum Studies from Johns Hopkins.
Welcome to you both and I'll turn
it over to you, take it away.
>> Hello everyone.
Welcome and thank you for joining us for
this event, the World Digital Library,
a Free Multilingual Collection of
Cultural Treasures from Around the World.
Thank you, Cheryl and Kathy for organizing
the conference and for including the WDL.
Today we want to talk to you about the
World Digital Library and show you how
to bring the World Digital
Library into your classroom.
>> Hello, I'm Cecilia Penaloza,
the Program Specialist of WDL.
>> And I'm the Description
Coordinator, Carissa Pastuch.
When you are done today we hope you will
walk away with a better understanding of how
to use WDL primary resources as tools
to support your students research.
>> In other words, we would like you to be
comfortable searching using the main features
of the site in guiding your
students to navigate our collection.
>> Imagine providing your
students free access to treasures
from around the globe without
leaving your classroom.
Your students can examine a 16th Century
map of Portuguese and Spanish discoveries.
You can do that with maps from the WDL.
Here at the top left is one example, we call
it the Walter Mueller Map [assumed spelling].
It's titled Map of the Entire World.
It was created in 1507 and was the first map
to depict a separate Western
Hemisphere with the name America.
>> The other atlas pictured here is
titled [foreign word] or General Atlas
of all the Islands of the World, in English.
The atlas consist of 111 maps representing
all the islands and peninsulas of the world,
and showing all the discoveries made by European
explorer from the 1400 to the mid-16th Century.
>> During the first years in elementary students
can be struggling with text and reading.
Using maps or photos from WDL can
lead to engagement and allow students
to read these items instead of text.
For some of those students this is something
that can boost their confidence
and increase participation.
You're probably asking how to get to WDL.
To get to WDL you simply type
www.wdl.org into your browser
and this will take you to the WDL homepage.
>> If by any chance you don't remember our
URL exactly, just type World Digital Library
into your browser and you should be
seeing WDL listed at the very top.
>> Here you see a screenshot of the
WDL homepage, which is hyperlinked
to the site so you can just click and go.
The World Digital Library is
a free multilingual collection
of cultural treasures from around the world.
>> The World Digital Library
or WDL as we call it
as an [inaudible] accessible
Internet based digital collection
where you can find the world's
cultural treasures.
Items showcased in WDL can you give a
sense of the history of humanity as well
as highlight achievements of many nations.
Presented here is a manuscript page by a
master of literature, Gustave Flaubert,
the author of Madame Bouvard et .
Flaubert fiercely worked and reworked his
writings until he reached the memorable style
that generations of readers have enjoyed.
We can see this process exemplified
here in his worked titled [inaudible].
This is the kind of treasure that
makes WDL different and relevant.
>> Our ultimate goal is to promote
cross-cultural awareness and understanding.
WDL is in essence a collaborative initiative
undertaken by the Library of Congress
and a large of number partner libraries,
museums, archives and cultural institutions
from around the world in
cooperation with UNESCO,
the United Nations Educational
Scientific and Cultural Organization.
>> The item on the top left hand side
of the slid is a [inaudible] fragment
called The Curse of Artemisia.
It is written in Ancient Greek and
dates from the late 4th Century BCE.
The middle item is one of the [inaudible]
dictionaries of old Spanish, [foreign word],
one of the languages of the Incas.
At the bottom left is an Arabic work by
[inaudible] from the Canon of Medicine.
[Inaudible] is considered one of
the most significant Islamic writers
of the Islamic Golden Age.
>> Partners may include institutions,
foundations and private companies
that contribute to the project in other ways.
For example, by sharing technology, convening
or cosponsoring meetings,
or contributing financially.
Currently WDL has content from
190 partners in 81 countries.
>> Our digital collection nowadays is
composed of more than 12,000 items.
Among those, manuscripts, maps, rare books,
prints and photographs, films
and sound recordings.
>> WDL is not an encyclopedic
library, it is a curated collection.
Content on the WDL is selected by partner
institutions in accordance with guidelines set
by the WDL Content Selection Committee.
Content is chosen for its cultural and
historical importance with dual regard
to recognition of the achievements
of all countries and cultures
over a wide range of time periods.
>> We are not custodians of the physical object.
The objects remain in the custody
of their housed institution.
Let's take a manuscript from the
National Library of France as an example.
This is Raynard Cycle [foreign
word], it's titled in French.
This is the most famous set of animal
stories produced during the Middle Ages.
>> WDL has the digital representations
taken from the original object,
in this case a manuscript,
and offers it for download
for educational purposes
while the National Library
of France keeps the actual
manuscript under their stewardship.
>> WDL has legal permission to
give access to the digital item.
To offer a multilingual [inaudible] description
of the object, and it's cultural relevance
in a way that will be understandable
for all global audiences.
>> Let's go back to the home page.
All bibliographic information
or metadata, navigation,
and supporting content are
translated into seven languages.
These include Arabic, English, Spanish,
French, Portuguese, Russian, and Chinese.
These are the six languages of the
United Nations plus Portuguese.
Portuguese was included because of the National
Library of Brazil's participation as one
of the original founding institutions of WDL.
Translations are done by human
translators and not machines.
This feature lengthens and complicates
site development and maintenance
but brings WDL closer to the
goal of being truly universal.
You can toggle between languages by clicking
on the language icon at the top right
of the screen as is circled here.
>> Let me clarify it a little bit more.
Books, manuscripts, maps and other primary
materials on the site are not translated,
but presented in their original languages.
One hundred twenty eight languages are
represented in WDL, including many lesser known
and endangered languages, such
as [inaudible] and Cherokee.
>> Here you see a screenshot of an
item detail page or record on WDL.
You can get to this page by clicking on
the reference image or title of the item.
This particular item is called The Tale
of Genji and is often considered the
first great novel in world literature
and one of the best known classic
works in Japanese literature.
Added value on our site includes
consistent, high quality metadata.
Each item is described by a consistent
set of [inaudible] information relating
to its geographical, temporal and topical
coverage, among other requirements.
Often you hear the definition of
metadata as metadata is data about data.
This definition is correct, metadata
summarized basic information about data
which in this case is the content,
be it a manuscript, book or print.
Consistent metadata provides the foundation for
a site that is easy and interesting to explore
and that helps to reveal
connections between items.
Author and date created are
examples of metadata.
Clicking on the author here will
take you to a list of all WDL content
that has the same creator, which
in this case is Murasaki Shikibu.
WDL currently has seven items by this author,
which were shared by National Diet Library,
Library of Congress and the
[inaudible] State Library.
Having the ability to filter through that
metadata makes it much easier for someone
to locate a specific document or
to make connections between items.
The metadata also improves
exposure to external search engines.
>> WDL has descriptions for each item.
These descriptions are intended
to answer two questions,
what is the item and why is it significant.
This information provides content for user and
is designed to spark the curiosity of students
and the general public to learn more
about the cultural [inaudible] country.
Here is a screenshot of the options
one can use to explore WDL content.
On the top left hand corner of the
WDL homepage you see the word explore.
If you click on that a dropdown
menu will appear.
>> Now we're going to discuss
sorting and a free text search.
Explore is simply a way of browsing a
site using one or more filtering options.
These options include place, time
period, topic, type of item or format,
language and contributing institution.
Each browsing session can be narrowed down using
filters until one reaches the desired result.
>> The first option to filter is place.
This option allows you to sort content by
visual graphics [inaudible] of the resource.
When cataloging, our metadata specialist
uses modern place names [inaudible] region,
country, [inaudible] and city.
>> If the content does not deal with a
geographic subject, for example works dealing
with religions, science or mathematics, we use
the region or country or origin of the author
or where that person primarily
worked to classify the item.
Therefore, these items still exist and
are browsable in a geographic context even
if they're not about a particular place.
>> Time period allows you to filter
by the date the item was created.
Topic allows you to sort by topic
drawn from the Dewey Decimal System.
>> Type of item or format allows
you to sort items by format.
For example, books, journals,
manuscripts, maps, etcetera.
>> Language allows you to sort
by the language of the content.
Note that items with no linguistic
content, such as photograph,
will not be sorted using this [inaudible].
>> And finally you can sort by contributing
institution, which is just sorting according
to the institution that contributed the content.
In addition to sorting, the search box,
as shown here in the middle of the screen,
circled in red, can be used to
conduct a keyword search of the site.
This is probably the easiest way to
get an item about a particular topic.
You just type in a keyword and hit enter and
all of the metadata descriptions and full text
of printed books on the site will be searched.
Let me briefly pause here
to provide an anecdote.
One of the teachers in residence
here at Education Outreach, Tom,
described how he effectively used the
WDL for a project with first graders.
He used the website for a unit he called Long
Ago and Now, which basically asks young students
to compare their life with one long ago.
What they tried last year somewhat
successfully was to extend the idea
and add a geographical component to the project.
They asked students to look ago
in different parts of the world.
They performed a keyword search
together on WDL using the term children.
Results included photographs of children from
many cultures and places, including [inaudible],
China, Hungary, and children
from various backgrounds
and ethnicities, such as [inaudible] children.
These photos are photos that these
young students can easily analyze
for some basic similarities and differences
between themselves and those pictured.
WDL photos and other materials are almost always
more nuanced than a photo students will find
in their textbooks or other online resources.
And engaging this material encourages
reflection that other visual resources may not.
>> In order to illustrate our display in some
features let's [inaudible] look at an example
for one item [inaudible] of the book
titled Women of the Empire in War Time .
This book is from our partners
at the British Library.
It was published in 1916 to celebrate the
contribution made by British women in support
of the allies during World War I.
To view the digital images of the item
click on the reference image circle here.
Clicking on the reference image
will take you to the item display.
>> Here you see the item description in English
which explains what the item
is and why it's significant.
>> The feature highlighted
here is great for students.
It's a text to speech conversion, which
is a function that allows users to listen
to the metadata and description
in all seven languages.
Just click on this button to listen to the text.
>> To change the item display
to another language,
just toggle between the languages
using the language icon.
Here is an example of the same record
in Arabic for Women of the Empire
in War Time or [foreign word] in Arabic.
Using the text to speech function you can listen
to the description and metadata in Arabic.
Again, just click the button
to listen to the text.
You may have noticed that the text
to speech function button has moved
to the left side of the screen.
This is because the orientation of the
language has changed from left to right,
and so has the language interface.
>> Display here is the same item, Women
of the Empire in War Time in Chinese.
Click the text to speech button,
and don't expect that I will
read Chinese, because I don't.
>> Now we'd like to show you
the item display function.
Again, you click on the reference image
and you'll go to the item display.
It will take you to this screen.
Once you've clicked on the reference image each
item can be viewed through the zoom features.
Use the arrows at the bottom of the page
to scroll through the pages of the book.
Item detail will take you
back to the item record.
>> You can zoom in into any page
of a book or any part of a map.
To zoom in or out use the zoom button located
at the bottom right of the display panel.
[Inaudible] included in books
such as maps have been digitized
and are presented with the zoom feature.
>> Another way to discover items on
the WDL site is the timelines feature.
Each timeline allows users to zero
in on particular time periods.
WDL currently has four timeline options, these
include Chinese books, manuscripts, maps,
and prints, illuminated manuscripts from
Europe, U.S. history and world history.
We're currently developing
a timeline for World War I
to commemorate the U.S. entry into the war.
All timelines are curated.
Let's look briefly at the
world history timeline.
>> After clicking on the world
history timeline options,
the first item that appears
chronologically is the [inaudible].
We're emphasizing the first date on the
Mayan calendar which mark the year 3372 BCE.
Seen here is a small section of one of
the panels of the magnificent [inaudible],
one of the four surviving Mayan [inaudible].
To continue moving through time click and
drag the time bar at the bottom of the screen
or use the arrow to the right and left of
the display item in the middle of the screen.
You will encounter interesting dates and topics.
This document can also [inaudible]
interactive map.
>> Yes, Cecilia, interactive maps
are an extension of the timeline.
What we wanted to accomplish with
interactive maps was basically
to provide a spatial representation of
the documents included on each timeline.
Here you see the World History interactive map,
which as we mentioned pulls
from the curated timeline.
You can use this option to see where
these items fall geographically.
The text box, as you see here, is the
summary of the timeline [inaudible].
Once closed you can see the green
circles with a number inside.
Each circle and number represents
the number of items for that region.
You can click on the number to get
to the gallery display of the items.
And click on the reference image
to go to the record of that item.
Alternatively, you can click on the
region provided at the top of the gallery
which is linked to all items in the WDL
collection that deal with that region.
We're exploring other options for teachers
to pull WDL content and compare with content
from other sites and institutions currently.
>> Please note now the helpful links
that we are putting together for you.
In closing, you can [inaudible] what
you can learned during this presentation
by continuing exploring and
navigating the site on your own.
We encourage you to take
some time now to explore
and ask us any questions that you might have.
We want you to know that you, teachers, are
a very important segment of our audience.
It is key for us to know that we
are serving your appropriately
and that we are giving you
thoughtful and provoking content.
It is important for us to know that you are
-- your students are engaged with the content,
which in many ways depends on
your own engagement with it.
We encourage you to look at the site and examine
how it can better serve you and your curriculum.
Find the connection that might exist between
your lesson plans and our collection.
WDL is a research tool which
needs to be used creatively.
Remember that and feel free
to contact us at any time.
We will be happy to help.
>> Thank you, guys.
Now we would like to take some time
to perform an exercise with you.
We'd like for you to play around
with the search function on the site.
Enter www.wdl.org into your browser and perform
a keyword search using the word children.
Look at the results.
Do you think your students could use any
of these as we have discussed earlier?
Can they use these pictures
and compare them to themselves?
Would your students find this helpful?
If so or if not, how?
>> What are the connections that you
see between the life of those pictures
in the photograph and your students?
We trust that you are creative, that
you will facilitate this encounter
between your students and our content.
That's [inaudible] that we need
[inaudible] to help us reach your students.
So try to create a narrative that helps us to
showcase our content and help your students
to get more knowledge about
the world [inaudible].
>> So are you guys coming across various
ethnicities, photos, what type of formats?
What do you think would be particularly helpful?
Do you think a print or photograph
may be more helpful?
Do you think a map could be more helpful?
>> We are always amazed when we
encounter teachers and they say to us
that they are somehow complicated
trying to explain
to their kids about the different religions.
And we always point out to them that we
have wonderful Bibles, wonderful [inaudible]
that perhaps the idea to enter those
kind of subjects is to go first
for the artistic [inaudible] of the images, and
that helps a lot because as kids get engaged
in the image it's much easier
to jump into more heavy content.
>> Hi, everyone, this is Kathy McWiggin
[assumed spelling] from the Library of Congress.
I'd like to ask Carissa and Cecilia some
questions from the beginning of the program.
There was a question that came in about the
use of content and can I use the content.
Can you talk about the copyright for
the items on World Digital Library?
>> Content provided on WDL is downloadable
and can be used for educational purposes.
Any format of content.
You can use a map, you can use the
manuscript, the book, all pages of a book,
and foldout maps are downloadable.
>> This is Cecilia here.
I would like to point out to you
that our collection is growing.
We make releases of new content
every two or three weeks.
And that means that sometimes you might
encounter not exactly what you are looking for,
but this is a collection that is growing.
We depend many ways of the willingness of
the institutions to share their content.
So but we are very aware of
the needs that teachers have,
so we're trying to fill those gaps.
>> Carissa and Cecilia, I was recording
the questions as they were coming through,
so I'll give you a few other questions
that were brought up within this session.
And I know Jason, you handled some of these,
but we'll just maybe not every
was paying attention to the chat.
But Jennifer Abbott wrote, "Are print
artifacts transcribed for easy reading
or are there only scans of the documents?"
>> Well, we use scans that
come from different sources.
And actually the zoom feature
will allow the students
to get very, very close to the material.
So there's not a percent translation
of each page, you will see the page
and that will really increase the
visibility of the entire book.
Another thing that we have to clarify,
we don't have just one image of one page
in a book, we have the entire book.
If the book has 300 pages, the scans are 300.
>> And back to the transcription
issue, transcriptions are only provided
in extremely famous works, otherwise we will
not provide transcriptions of these items.
>> Great.
>> We just don't have the resources to do that.
>> Great. Okay, I've been forwarded
a couple other questions and I'm --
if it's okay I'm going to go ahead
and ask those to you now, too.
How about, what are some of the
most viewed or downloaded resources?
>> I would say that one of the most popular
right now is the Florentine [inaudible].
We have a very important collection of
[inaudible] and we needed the last one,
[inaudible] the last part
of the [inaudible] Empire.
And we got it after a long negotiation
with [inaudible], a library in Italy.
And we scanned all the pages, and those
[inaudible] extremely, extremely solicited
by teachers and actually academics, also,
because it's the first time it's
available online to be seen and study.
>> Well, thank you.
I think we have time for a few more questions.
Oh, here, Desiree asks, "Is
there a way to request documents
or recordings that you don't currently have?"
>> Well, we receive suggestions, but as I
said before, we depend on the institutions
that we are negotiating to get scans from.
Now, if the teachers wanted to let us know that
they are very interested in a certain item,
of course we will welcome that suggestion
and try to negotiate for you to get the scans
and the description, which is the most
important part, in the seven languages.
It's a complicated work, but we love
it, so we will make the best of trying
to get you the content that you need.
>> We do have certain content that we
prioritize, such as Mezzo American [inaudible],
Chinese rare books, so we do encourage our
partners to donate these types of materials,
and sometimes seek it out if need be.
>> Great. Okay, here's another
question that's coming in.
I'll type it as I'm speaking.
But as you work with teachers are
you learning particular strategies
that teachers are often using with this content?
In other words, how are they -- how are teachers
around the world using the World Digital Library
and what seems to be working best for them?
>> That is a good question.
We try to learn a lot from the feedback
we get, and webinars such as this one,
and talk with the teachers in
residence here at Education Outreach
to learn how teachers are using these in
their classrooms, learn how they use our site.
So we really depend on you in a forum
such as this to respond and let us know.
We hope that you can perhaps
identify gaps in our timeline
or gaps in our content and let us know.
Feel free to e-mail us, Tweet us and
let us know where these gaps exist,
how we can better fulfill things
that will work with your curriculum.
So please respond, let us know.
>> And a related question came in, "Do you have
teachers using this content all over the world?"
>> Yes, most definitely.
We can hear from them, from [inaudible]
from Albania, we can hear teachers
that write from -- to us from Russia.
It's quite amazing for us.
Sometimes we're not totally
aware of the access that we have
to these remote places in the world.
So, yes, we have responses
from teachers from all
over the place, and that's very, very exciting.
>> And we can track our users.
Of course we can't tell, you know, if our users
are a teacher or what their profession is,
but we can track them and right now our
number one user by country is China.
>> That's very interesting.
A related -- different question
came in, I'll type it in.
This really has to do with the digitization.
Is -- you know, we know you digitized
resources from all over the world,
is digitization ever a problem
in places like the Third World
where resources may not be as available?
>> Yes, that's a great question
and the answer is yes.
There is very much a different level of
financial possibilities for people who are
in Africa and South America, Central
America, even, part of India.
So we do -- we are aware of those
problems, and at that point you have to talk
with educational ministers with consortiums
that found those kind of initiative projects,
because universities sometimes do a lot of that.
We here, where we work, we don't digitize.
We have some centers for digitization
and that help us a lot to go by areas.
But definitely, in Africa, for example, we have
a lot to do, and to teach them how to digitize
with the standards that we need,
because sometimes we receive things
that we really cannot put in our site because
it will not be using all the resources
that we have, because the scans are too
weak, because they're totally imperfect.
So there's a lot of capacity building to be done
and we are very aware and working on that area.
>> Our major locations that
we focused on is Iraq,
Uganda and Egypt, our capacity building that is.
>> [Inaudible] asks specifically
about projects underway in India.
I believe Cuddy [assumed
spelling] is from India.
>> We currently have one partner in India,
in Cashmere, but we are currently working
to recruit other partners and would
love to have more partners in India.
>> On a related note let's say somebody
like Cuddy wanted to help you guys out,
could she do that as an educator?
>> Well, if she has any connection
with the national library, for example,
she can put us in contact with them
and tell them about our initiative.
Of course, some people ask, also, if we
will be adding new languages, for example.
And, yes, it's a goal, but we are working
with the resources that we have right now.
We would love to have more languages, and
that's a lot of work for the translators,
for the editors, but most definitely for --
to accomplish the mission to be
universal, we need to have more languages.
So if India is one of the countries
that we would like to have, yes.
And we do have a lot of content about India,
we have actually the Constitution of India.
>> Great. This is fascinating.
We unfortunately are just
about at the end of our time.
So Carissa or Cecilia, do you have any final
words before I kind of do my final housekeeping?
>> I just wanted to reinforce that we
recognize that teachers are indeed one
of the most important segments of our audience.
And we rely heavily on their feedback to
better our site and to select content.
So please, I encourage you to respond
here in the chat room, respond by a Tweet,
any way you can, be interactive and let
us know how we can better serve you.
>> And just now I thank you -- a big thank you
for all of you for the attention, and please,
come back to our site and
explore what is going on there.
>> Thank you.
>> I second that.
Thank you to Carissa and Cecilia
for a wonderful presentation,
and for everybody who joined
as attendees, as well.
We would love to have your feedback.
If you look at the content on the
slide right now, there's a link.
You can click on that survey link
and please take a few moments
and provide very helpful feedback
to us on the presentation.
You will also receive any e-mail within
five business days with directions
to access a certificate for
one instructional hour.
In case you want to use this session as,
you know, continuing education units,
that's something that you could do as well.
Thanks again, everybody for joining us.
Good night.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.